good morning Hank it's Monday January
8th Sara and I are about to drive out of
Asheville on our way to Birmingham
Alabama I would like to congratulate you
on successfully completing the
Strawberry Hill challenge except that
you didn't complete it Hank as you know
I had surgery on my mouth a few weeks
ago after they sewed my gum back into my
mouth my mouth tasted like cement and
blood and burnt meat and you know how
after any dental procedure they make you
drink that like green gross minty
alcohol II stuff and then spit
Strawberry Hill tastes exactly like that
spit project idea the Brotherhood 2.0
Book Club all read a book you suggest if
you read a book I suggest my first
suggestion either what is the what by
Dave Eggers or we wish to inform you
that tomorrow we will be killed with our
families by Philip gurevich Oh John it's
Tuesday January night I'm in Detroit
Michigan I'm standing in the only place
in the continental United States where
you can look and see Canada which you
are doing right now I'm also standing in
front of General Motors headquarters
it's a very very big building
I've accepted an invitation from General
Motors to visit the North American
International Auto Show
in Detroit Michigan I was invited as
because I write for a few environmental
blocks and there's some environmental
things going on
those are my values this is not my
pallidus here
have the weirdest prettiest fake
waterfall ever and it spells things
so lame
as for the Brotherhood 2.0 book club I'm
really excited that you're giving me
opportunities to read so many books
about genocide I love genocide good
morning Hank it's dirt what it's
Wednesday January 10th boy I'm out of it
hi girls who are being used as objects
to sell other objects sorry about the
patriarchal oppression I was inspired by
your video blog yesterday to calculate
my own carbon footprint so I'm gonna go
to BP comm and do it Hank I produce 16
tons of carbon a year that is lower than
the United States average of eighteen
point five eight but it's still really
bad 16 tons of carbon I just read on the
internet that it only cost $6 per ton to
get rid of your carbon footprint ah that
means that it's only gonna cost me like
I'm not very good at math hold on a
minute call Daniel hey how's it going
what 16 times six it's 96 do you see how
fast he did that he doesn't have a
calculator 96 dollars a year that's what
it would cost to offset my carbon
consumption if I pay Al Gore $96 I will
not have any global warming attached to
my name I think you can pay him directly
I think you just write him a check and
he just takes care of it he does he eats
the carbon that's exactly right that's
how he does it he eats the carbon and
then when he poops it out it's actually
political gold good afternoon John it is
Thursday January 11th so I was just
watching my video from January 9th I'm
paying the price for not being
commensurate with my values I don't
actually remember this tiny chicken but
I'm almost positive that we had an
encounter because this tiny chicken has
laid tiny eggs in my head and the baby
tiny chickens are feeding on my brain
they're eating my brain and their poop
is coming out my nose I've got a little
bit of a problem and I was hoping that
you or maybe one of our viewers could
help me out I was going to Detroit right
so I figured I'd have a bunch of
business card to print it out I used an
online service and I uploaded my files
and they sent me a bunch of business
cards like that I
like a nice dirty cardstock and on the
back it supposed to be like this one
which I got printed up at Kinkos this
one on the back says this and on the
front says this what am I supposed to do
with this
John viewers what do I do with one
hundred three inch by one and a half
inch cards
that's a ego geek on them so far my only
idea is to tape them all over my face I
would walk 500 miles and I would walk
500 ball see this is there's a to me not
a punishment not I don't know to me it's
not a punishment please need to come up
with better punishments is what I'm
saying good morning Hank it's Friday
January 12th this video blog post is
going to consist entirely of ideas
misprinted business card utilization
ideas if you had a hole punch a lot of
patience and a lot of dental floss you
could make Katherine a dress since you
just got married you can use them to
write very terse thank-you notes in very
small handwriting you could wallpaper
every room in your dollhouse everybody
thinks you have a dollhouse now
punishment ideas I'm just going to pick
punishment ideas from things that are
currently in our living room
several of our books would make
excellent punishments this is the
continuum history of apocalypticism it's
1100 pages long it's pretty punishing
don't you think it would be a good
punishment if you had to do your happy
dance for three minutes and 30 seconds
but you could only do it at five-second
clips at a time so you had to have a
total of 70 dances in 70 different
locations I'd be pretty good punishment
or maybe that should be a project we
could intersperse our happy dances you
do 35 I do 35 that has some appeal for
me any interest
you